wir bleiben wie es im deutschen
bundestag der gibt es nämlich noch einen
gesetzentwurf der fraktionen spd dem
ausland sich die grünen und fdp der
jetzt hier noch eine knappe halbe stunde
beraten werden soll denn die gasspeicher
in deutschland weisen die niedrigsten
füllstände der letzten 15 jahre auf und
das ist gerade angesichts der
angespannten lage wegen des frischen
krieges sehr besorgniserregend und die
bundesregierung beziehungsweise durch
diesen gesetzentwurf die fraktionen
wollen den betreibern von gasspeicher
anlagen vorgaben machen wie zu wie viel
prozent die speicher mindestens gefüllt
sein müssen im sommer sollen die
betreiber dann
diese gasspeicher erfüllen als erstes
spricht dazu ingrid nestle von den
grünen sehr geehrte frau präsidentin
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen die
ukraine krise hat viele dramatische
folgen sie hat auch gefährliche folgen
für die gasversorgung unserer industrie
aber auch für das wohnen für die frage
haben menschen ein warmes dach überm
kopf zum einen deshalb weil viele viele
geflüchtete aus der ukraine
natürlich nicht alle in den
nachbarländern bleiben können sondern
viele auch bei uns sind und deswegen
würde diesen gesetz auch dafür gesorgt
dass das seine aufgaben mit hoher
dringlichkeit
erleichterung beim bau für die
rechtzeitige fertigstellung neuer
unterkünfte gegeben sind aber es geht
natürlich auch darum dass die häuser die
wir längst haben dass die auch im
nächsten winter warm sein werden und
auch das ist ein ganz zentraler
bestandteil dieses gesetzentwurfes wie
sorgen wir dafür dass die gasspeicher
zum nächsten winter tatsächlich gut
gefüllt ist sind so dass wir guten mutes
in den winter gehen können der schon
letztes jahr haben wir gesehen dass die
speicher die von gazprom töchtern
betrieben worden sind
erstaunliche lehrern den winter
getrieben worden sind russland ist
unsere abhängigkeit von den fossilen
energien um druck auf uns auszuüben
massiven druck und das wollen wir
beenden
[Applaus]
ich glaube wir wissen gar nicht mehr was
für ein schatz unsere sichere
energieversorgung ist und ich frage
nicht ob wir es am ende des übernächsten
winter es immer noch nicht wissen mein
eindruck ist dass der ernste lage noch
nicht überall angekommen ist und auch
deshalb ist dieses gesetz so wichtig und
so dringend das ist ein baustein in
einem großen puzzle das wir legen uns
zusammensetzen müssen um unabhängig zu
werden von den fossilen und
energiesicherheit wieder bereitzustellen
und kurzfristig geht es aber eben auch
darum die energie für den nächsten
winter bereitzustellen deshalb dieses
gesetz dieses gesetz das dafür sorgt
dass diejenigen die die gasspeicher
nutzen sie tatsächlich auch befüllen
müssen und nicht strategisch gegen uns
verwenden dürfen wir versuchen dabei so
weit es geht auf marx sich instrumente
zurückzugreifen
wir sagen aber da wo sie nicht mehr
funktionieren da greifen wir auch
regulierend ein weil die
versorgungssicherheit mit gas im winter
das höhere gut ist
die auf ein paar weitere änderungen ein
die wir jetzt noch im parlamentarischen
verfahren eingebracht haben wichtig ist
uns auch dass
wenn tatsächlich der marktgebiets
verantwortliche dann auf kosten der
gaskunden selbst speicherkapazitäten
buchen muss um diese zu befüllen für den
kommenden winter dass klargestellt ist
zu welchen kosten der dies tut nämlich
die durchschnittlich kostengünstigsten
entgelte letzten drei jahre das bedeutet
die bundesnetzagentur
berechnet den durchschnitt der
auktionserlöse für jeweils ein jahr und
das machen wir für die drei
zurückliegenden jahre und von den so
ermittelten drei durchschnittswerten für
einzel jahre nehmen wir den
kostengünstigsten wir haben aber auch
noch einmal klar gestellt dass der markt
die beats verantwortliche dass es
trading europe bei uns in deutschland
der tatsächlich eine wichtige rolle in
dem gesetz spielt nicht derjenige ist
der entscheiden darf oder muss sondern
dass letztlich die entscheidung und wir
wollen ganz bewusst auch ein
entscheidungsspiel raum haben wenn es
auch im sommer extrem hohe gaspreise
geben sollte wenn es auch im sommer
extrem knappheiten bei der anlieferung
von gas geben sollte dass das
bundesministerium entscheiden kann na
gut dann ist es vielleicht besser nur
mit 85 prozent reicher stand in den
winter zu gehen ja das ist nicht ganz so
bequem aber es immer noch viel bequemer
an seinen wago aber wir zahlen nicht
jeden preis wir zahlen nicht jeden preis
für gas an putin
meine damen und herren ich komme zum
ende die lage ist ernst und das ist doch
nur ein puzzlestein es geht darum den
ausbau der erneuerbaren energien auf
allen ebenen jetzt in den richtigen
turbo zu bringen es geht darum energie
effizienz voranzubringen gerade bei den
schlechtesten gebäuden es gibt ganz ganz
viel zu tun ich freue mich dass wir ein
baustein hier heute in diesem plenum zu
ende bringen können franken
der gesetzentwurf soll im mai in kraft
treten so wollen es die fraktionen
zumindest von spd bündnis 90/die grünen
und fdp wie die opposition zu diesem
gesetzentwurf steht das wird uns jetzt
andreas jung sagen er ist sprecher für
klimaschutz in der unionsfraktion
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen die kollegin dr nestlé gerade
festgestellt die lage ist ernst und in
der vorhergehenden debatte um einzelne
redner in frage gestellt ob die
opposition in dieser woche ihrer
verantwortung gerecht wird gestatten sie
mir dazu zwei bemerkungen
insbesondere weil das ja das einzige
gesetz ist über das wegen dieser woche
debattieren neben den debatten über den
haushalt die fortgesetzt werden im
weiteren beratung dass dieses gesetz
jetzt abgestimmt werden kann heute liegt
daran dass wir als opposition auf die
anhörungsrechte verzichteten damit ein
beschleunigtes verfahren ermöglichte
[Applaus]
und zweitens wir werden heute in diesem
gesetz
zustimmen wir werden zustimmen und es
ist die konkrete übersetzung dessen was
wir bei der sondersitzung vor vier
wochen allgemein erklärt haben wo in
dieser krise entscheidungen notwendig
sind da sind wir bereit dazu gemeinsam
verantwortung zu übernehmen
und warum ist es notwendig bei diesem
gesetz weil wir zu beginn dieses winters
festgestellt haben dass die annahme dass
der markt es richten
würde nicht zugetroffen hat weil wir
historisch niedrige füllstände hatten zu
beginn dieses winters über die gründe
kann man diskutieren und die mögen zu
einem teil markt getrieben sein weil wir
im winter sehr hohe preise hätten im
sommer sehr hohe preise hatten nicht wie
sonst eher niedrige preise und der mag
es sein dass der ein oder andere das was
regulär gemacht wird nämlich dass nur zu
niedrigen preisen im winter einkauf zum
zuhören im winter zu verkaufen nicht
gemacht hat es mag ein kleiner teil der
erklärung sein der maßgebliche teil der
erklärung ist aber der den ingrid nestle
gesagt hat 20 prozent unserer
gasspeicher in deutschland sind unter
dem einfluss von gazprom und dort im
unterschied zu anderen hatten wir die
historisch niedrigen füllstände und
deshalb gilt es jetzt konsequenzen zu
ziehen
die konsequenzen müssen über dieses
gesetz hinaus gehen sie hatte sechs ein
puzzlestein wir müssen weitere
konsequenzen sind die haben zu tun mit
der frage wie schaffen wir es zusätzlich
kapazitäten an gas zu bekommen nur dann
können ja die verpflichtung über die wir
heute sprechen erfüllt werden und wir
brauchen eine größere sensibilität für
unseren umgang mit kritischer
infrastruktur für die frage wie sind
eigentumsverhältnisse wie sind
transaktionen bei kritischer
infrastruktur an dieser erkenntnis kommt
man nicht vorbei wenn man sich den
prozess anschaut wie der größte deutsche
gasspeicher in rehden veräußert wurde in
einem prozess der jahre 2012 bis
2015 genau dieser gasspeicher der
aktuellen füllstand von 1 prozent hat
wir müssen diese diskussion weiterführen
und wir werden diese diskussion
weiterführen wir halten den weg der
jetzt beschritten wird im grundsatz für
richtig dass füllstände vorgegeben
werden zu bestimmten zeiten zu beginn
des winters im dezember dann zu 90
prozent
man kann über konkrete regelungen
diskutieren die diskussion muss auch
weiter gehen trotzdem ist notwendig das
ws entscheiden damit die dinge umgesetzt
werden können es ist richtig dass die
verantwortung festgemacht wird bei dem
markt gebietsverantwortlichen
unterstützen wir ausdrücklich
man kann darüber diskutieren ob die
frage der kostenverteilung so gelöst
werden sollte wie es jetzt gemacht wird
nämlich in einer umlage oder ob ein
anderer weg gesucht werden sollte diese
frage haben wir diskutiert die haben
auch die fraktionen der anke
diskutiert diese diskussion wird
sicherlich weitergehen genauso wie die
frage wie weit ein markteingriff gehen
sollte ob es notwendig ist dass verträge
wenn es zu einem 1 11 kommt völlig quasi
untergehen oder ob sie lediglich über
wochen werden das sind fragen die
schwierig zu beantworten sind und
deshalb begrüßen wir es ausdrücklich
dass ihm das gesetz aufgenommen wurde
eine verpflichtende evaluierung im
nächsten jahr damit man im lichte der
erkenntnisse der nächsten monate hier
möglicherweise konsequenzen ziehen kann
dass auch dieses gesetz befristet wurde
das hat uns unsere zustimmung erreicht
hat
[Applaus]
unterm strich komme ich damit
zum ende wir noch mal betonen wir können
das somit tragen wir sind sicher dass
die diskussion weiter gehen wird die
union wird diesem gesetz zustimmen
finden
[Applaus]
das wort hat der kollege bank wirbt für
die spd frau zu
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen liebe
kollegen die wir bürgerinnen bürgern
dieser freitag ist ein guter tag für die
versorgungssicherheit in deutschland und
europa und für mehr unabhängigkeit von
den verbrecherischen regime in russland
meine damen und herren
aber seien wir ehrlich unsere
abhängigkeit heute basiert auf den
fehlern der vergangenheit im jahr 2015
das wurde gerade schon gesagt hat sich
der russische gaskonzern gazprom ganz
legal den größten deutschen
erdgasspeicher rehden einverleibt über
eine tochtergesellschaft
kontrolliert russland seit dem de facto
ein fünftel der deutschen gasspeicher
kapazitäten mit dem volumen des halben
bodensees das muss man sich mal
verdeutlichen der einschätzung damals
lautete kein problem die deutsche
versorgungssicherheit das nicht
gefährdet doch spätestens putins
verbrecherischen angriffskrieg hat uns
knallhart vor augen geführt dass wir uns
gewaltig getäuscht haben und das obwohl
uns viel gewarnt hatten
gazprom betreibt das politische geschäft
des kreml und lässt den reden der
speicher praktisch leer von dem halben
bodensee war also nur noch kleine
ententeich übrig heute aber gibt die
deutsche demokratie darauf eine starke
antwort wo der markt nicht mehr
funktioniert schafft wir verbindliche
regeln meine damen und herren wir
werden uns genau angesehen wer speicher
betreiber und der gaslieferant ist
beides darf nicht in einer hand kriegen
wir werden uns im einklang mit den neuen
eu richtlinien zum thema genau anschauen
welche firmen auf den europäischen
märkten unterwegs sind diese aufgabe
werden wir nicht nur in deutschland
sondern gemeinsam mit allen
mitgliedsstaaten der lösen
der kern dieses gesetzes sind die
verpflichtende mindest füllstände
80 zum ersten oktober 90 zum ersten
november und 40 zum ersten februar
so stellen wir sicher dass die
nachfragespitzen in den wintermonaten
ausgeglichen werden und das ist ein
wichtiges zeichen an die deutsche und
europäische bevölkerung unsere
gasspeicher werden immer so voll sein
dass unsere energieversorgung zu jeder
zeit gewährleistet ist in dem wohnzimmer
dieser republik sollst nicht im
bitterkalt werden und die maschinen
müssen weiter laufen können denn
deutschland
es ist aber auch ein wichtiges zeichen
nach moskau die deutsche demokratie ist
stark und erweist sich gerade in
krisenzeiten als handlungsfähig schnell
und flexibel meine damen und herren
zur wahrheit gehört aber auch wir
brauchen möglichst schnell alternativen
zum russischen gas und wir müssen den
ausbau der erneuerbaren energien endlich
den turbo zünden und das sommer paket
wird uns dafür den weg ebnen
die mindest für stände beim gas
erreichen wir mit dem prinzip so viel
markt wie möglich und so viel staat wie
nötig so müssen die speicher betreiber
zukünftig die einhaltung der füllstände
überwachen und wo die marke gesteuerte
bestellung nicht gewährleistet ist
schaffen wir neue instrumente es werden
strategische optionen ausgeschrieben und
so die befüllung der nicht genutzten
kapazitäten angereist was die neuen
eingriffsmöglichkeiten angehen liegt
unsere präferenz also ganz eindeutig bei
den kommerziellen methoden aber die vom
wirtschaftsministerium veranlassten
direkten ankäufer vom physischen gas
bleiben die ultima ratio und die balance
zwischen markt und im staatlichen
eingriff ist auch der spagat zwischen
versorgungssicherheit und möglichst
großer preisstabilität und ich denke da
haben wir einen ziemlich guten
kompromiss gefunden und wir werden diese
entwicklung weiter im auge behalten und
genau darum haben wir eine zweistufige
evaluation im gesetz verankert und das
gesetz befristet um diese und um die
anderen details haben wir sehr starke
wohnen den verbänden mit dem bmw k
innerhalb der fraktion und natürlich
auch innerhalb der ampel ich möchte mich
ganz ganz ausdrücklich dafür bedanken
dass wir zu einem guten kompromiss
gekommen sind wichtig ist dass dies ein
wichtiges zeichen an die deutsche und
europäische bevölkerung ist unsere
gasspeicher werden immer so voll sein
und die demokratie in diesem land ist
stark wir stehen zusammen um die
stabilität der versorgungssicherheit in
deutschland und europa sicherzustellen
vielen dank und
märz war das hat ja auch der hass
klimaschutzpaket von
bundeswirtschaftsminister robert habeck
angesprochen der dieser debatte auch
zuhört wird nicht selber sprechen
sondern hört den abgeordneten zu mit
diesem sommer paket es gibt ja auch ein
oster paket möchte robert habeck seine
klima schütze vorhaben umsetzen jetzt
steffen co träfe die fdp fraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte damen und herren beim letzten
mal unserer diskussion wurde ich
aufgefordert etwas zum
völkerrechtswidrigen angriffskrieg der
großen gegen die ukraine zu sagen er
bringt viel leid um dieses leid hat die
russische regierung auf dem gewissen und
der krieg muss sofort beendet werden
aber das ist die eine sache die andere
sache ist auch wenn wir darüber reden
müssen die immer die mit schuld des
westens betrachten der westen namentlich
die usa nichts dafür getan
diese situation zu entschärfen im
gegenteil hat sogar noch provoziert und
wir müssten auch dazu sagen dass es
denkfabrik in den usa gibt die sich
gedanken machen wie russland de
stabilisiert werden kann und die sich
gedanken machen die gerade die ukraine
als aufmarschgebiet dieser politischen
die stabilisierung genutzt werden kann
und wenn wir darüber reden dann müssen
wir eben auch über die bio waffen labore
in der ukraine reden die gegen russland
gerichtet sind und viele viele andere
dinge
aber die zeit reicht an dieser stelle
leider nicht aus kommen wir zum
gesetzentwurf und zu unserem
entschließungsantrag also wir verstehen
nicht dass es da nicht eine flexible und
version gefunden worden ist und uns
interessiert doch nicht wie hoch die
füllstände der gasspeicher sind uns
interessiert doch wie lange es die
reichweite da müssen doch wissen wie
viel tage hier noch haben wenn uns dann
der gashahn zugedreht wird und deswegen
schlagen gehen diese lösung vor dass wir
eben diese 45 tages regel haben haben
und dann müssen eben die versorger
selber sehen wie hoch der füllstand ist
das ist doch logisch das ist doch dem
risiko angemessen 45 tage zum ersten und
dann natürlich im weiteren auf 90 tage
hinauf und so haben wir dann auch die
entsprechende
versorgungssicherheit meine damen und
herren aber versorgungssicherheit die
wird ja großflächig abgebaut und wir
haben jetzt sogar ein gericht das
entschieden hat dass der tagebau der
braunkohletagebau jänschwalde nicht
weitergeht das gericht hat sich hier
leider zu einer entscheidung
hinreißen lassen uns die
energieversorgung weiter abzuschnüren
wir haben eigentlich gerade festgestellt
dass wir mehr kohle brauchen wir haben
gerade festgestellt dass wir kernenergie
brauchen aber auch das wird von der
regierung torpediert und wir haben
gesehen wie sie das macht sie macht das
aus ideologischen gründen mit berichten
die gar keine sind die über die
richtigen anmerkungen der fachexperten
hinweggehen nur um nicht die sichere und
zuverlässige kernenergie hier bei uns zu
halten oder wieder mit einzuführen aber
das ist ja leider die politik der
altparteien da können wir ja leider
dieser stelle nichts machen das wird
sich vermutlich sofort setzen aber das
müssen sie ihren wählern dann und zum
procedere jetzt hat man also hier
schnell noch einen artfremden artikel
angefangen an dieses gesetz was also mit
dem ursprünglichen gesetzentwurf gar
nichts zu tun hat mit der gasversorgung
und das ist natürlich bezeichnet man
möchte da vielleicht die erste lesung
umgehen aber das ist kein guter stil
und das wirft auch kein gutes licht auf
die koalition hier einfach ja der
opposition die möglichkeit nimmt
bisschen länger zu diskutieren nein wir
haben jetzt zwei drei tage zeit gehabt
und ja leider ist das ein schlechter
stil aber den müssen wie gesagt sie
verantworten darunter
steffen kothe war das hat hier den
vorwurf hervorgebracht das ist biowaffen
labore in der ukraine geben würde dazu
nur der hinweis laut leiterin des un
büros für abrüstungsfragen liegen den
vereinten nationen keine hinweise auf
solche programme in der ukraine vor
kommen wir wieder zum thema gasspeicher
konrad stock mona für die fdp spricht
prozent sehr geehrte frau präsidentin
geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen die
ampel beweist mit diesem gesetz zu
füllstand vorgaben für geist für
gasspeicher anlagen so heißt das wort
handlungsfähigkeit
und es ist in diesen zeiten ein gutes
signal dass aus dem bundestag hinaus an
die bürgerinnen und bürger gesandt wird
dass dieses gesetz mit einer sehr
breiten mehrheit des hauses
verabschiedet wird und die diesem sinne
darf ich von seinen der freien
demokraten der cdu csu fraktion und auch
der fraktion der linken für die
zusammenarbeit an dieser stelle explizit
danken
denn
es geht um daseinsvorsorge für uns alle
und wer da mal wieder nicht mitmacht
spricht für sich mehr will ich dazu auch
gar nicht sagen
besondere zeiten erfordern besondere
maßnahmen und daraus folgt auch diese
maßnahmen zeitlich zu begrenzen
das gilt nicht nur für die maßnahmen mit
denen die ampel koalition in dieser
woche abermals schnell auf steigende
energiepreise reagiert hat es gilt auch
für dieses gesetz daher haben wir als
fdp bundestagsfraktion besonderen wert
darauf gelegt dass in diesem gesetz ein
monitoring der maßnahmen verankert wird
und dass seine gültigkeit auch zeitlich
begrenzt ist denn damit meine damen und
herren stellen wir sicher dass der
bundestag als demokratisch legitimierter
gesetzgeber die entwicklung am gasmarkt
sorgfältig verfolgen muss und dass er
dann auch zum richtigen zeitpunkt
sinnvolle anschluss regelungen treffen
muss
in den letzten tagen war zu lesen dass
in brüssel die deutschen aktivitäten in
der gasversorgung von russland
unabhängig zu werden verhalten
aufgenommen werden es gibt überlegungen
solche aktivitäten eben auch zu den
gasspeicher fragen auf eu ebene zu
bündeln um auch einen
überbietungswettbewerb der
mitgliedstaaten bei der suche nach nicht
russischen lieferanten zu verhindern und
dazu möchte ich nicht nur als energie
sondern als überzeugter europapolitiker
folgendes anmerk wir begrüßen den deal
der sich da zwischen der eu und den usa
abzeichnet und
wegen der technischen umsetzung der
speicheranforderungen ist jetzt aber
eile geboten
deswegen können wir heute und hier nicht
auf eine entscheidung dazu auf eu ebene
warten aber
das steht für uns einer engen abstimmung
in dieser frage mit unseren partnern in
der eu keineswegs im wege denn wir
freien demokraten setzen uns dezidiert
dafür ein dass die gemeinsame energie
politische schlagkraft der eu in
reaktion auf den verbrecherischen
angriff auf die ukraine auch wirklich
erhöht wird denn sosehr putins angriff
auf die ukraine ein angriff auf das
freiheitliche westliche
gesellschaftsmodell ist so sehr stehen
wir mit unseren partnern zusammen um es
zu verteidigen
und vor diesem hintergrund möchte ich in
diesen bedrückenden tagen mit einer
hoffnungs stiftende nachricht aus der
letzten woche enden liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen
der europäische verband für die
zusammenarbeit der
übertragungsnetzbetreiber für strom hat
die ukraine an das europäische stromnetz
angeschlossen
es ist gelungen es ist gelungen diese
technische herausforderung in kürzester
zeit zu meistern und meine damen und
herren es ist doch so unendlich viel
mehr als eine infrastrukturmaßnahme
es ist eine von vielen taten mit denen
die heldinnen und helden in der ukraine
unsere partner in der ganzen welt und
wir frieden und freiheit in europa hat
herzlichen dank
konrad stockmeier hat hier auch den
gemeinsamen ansatz der europäischen
union angesprochen und wir müssen dazu
sagen der eu gipfel der wurde nun
unterbrochen wir hatten ja eine
pressekonferenz von bundeskanzler olaf
scholz erwartet aber es gibt noch keine
einigung über die gas und energie
versorgung der europäischen staaten
gegeneinander gemeinsam vorgehen kann
deswegen wird der eu-gipfel demnächst
fortgesetzt die pressekonferenz findet
also dementsprechend natürlich erst
einmal nicht statt wir verfolgen das und
informieren sie
half lenkert spricht jetzt für die
linksfraktion sprechen für umweltpolitik
von großkonzernen großbanken die
spekulationsgewinne einfahren und in der
finanzkrise sich mit steuergeldern
retten lassen ablesbar von konzern bmw
aber auch gazprom es ist zeit diese
ablesbarkeit endlich zu beenden mit
weniger markt und leer statt
wenn der staat bei privaten schirm mit
geld einspringt muss doch im gegenzug
sichergestellt sein dass er an den
gewinnen und an den anteilen beteiligt
wird
wegen des unregulierten gasmarktes muss
deutschland im winter zittern ob das gas
zum heizen und für die industrie reicht
ja
putins aggressiver verbrecherischer
angriff zerstört menschenleben und
ukrainische städte wir verurteilen
diesen angriff aufs schärfste russland
muss diesen angriff sofort beenden
aber putin zerstören eben auch das
vertrauen in die zuverlässigkeit
russischer energie
und deshalb ist es unerlässlich
sicherzustellen dass genügend gas
rechtzeitig in die gasspeicher ein
gespeichert wird und daher wird die
linke dieses gesetz so auch für mindest
vorständen bei gasspeichern unterstützen
kolleginnen und kollegen auf einem markt
ohne regeln hat der staat keine
möglichkeiten wucherpreise von
spekulanten zu verhindern die gestrigen
vorschläge der koalition ja sie
verringern die energie armut etwas aber
die konzerne konzerne kassieren weiter
ab und das ist unerträglich
die linke für die abzüge bei
energiepreisen beenden wir fordern
staatliche preiskontrollen wir fordern
festpreise nachher stückkosten und 1 1
kassiert der spekulationsgewinne vielen
dank
ralph lenkert kündigt hier schon einmal
die zustimmung der linksfraktion an noch
einen redner dann stimmen wir die
abgeordneten über diesen gesetzentwurf
ab sowie über einen entschließungsantrag
der fdp fraktion in dem sie unter
anderem fordert aus dem treibhausgas
emissionen zertifikate der überaus
aufsteigen jetzt erst mal der letzte
redner in der debatte bernhard leid
[Applaus]
frau präsident sind liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen wenn man das letzter redner
am letzten plenartag im letzten
tagesordnungspunkt reden muss dann
sollte man sich glaube ich etwas sputen
war ich auch deswegen sag ja auch nichts
mehr zu sich und gasspeicher anlagen
dazu hat mein kollege herbert schon
einiges gesagt sondern ich will zur
änderung des baugesetzbuches etwas sagen
weil beides hat zwar nicht unbedingt
fachlich etwas zu tun aber beides hat
eine gemeinsame verursachung nämlich den
krieg in der ukraine und in vielen
beiträgen dass der haushaltswoche sind
die leistungen der kommunen auch der
vielen ehrenamtlichen engagierten
hervorgehoben worden ist ihnen gedankt
worden bei der aufnahme von flüchtlingen
bei der unterbringung aber jetzt stellt
sich die frage wie können wir denn neben
dank und anerkennung auch tatsächlich
unterstützung leisten und zu dem was der
bund tatsächlich auch tun kann gehört
hilfestellung beim bau aber auch bei den
genehmigungsverfahren und das machen wir
hier an dieser stelle sehr viel haben
die großen städte zunächst einmal
geregelt aber das thema ist im grunde
genommen in allen kommunen relevant und
deswegen will ich mich auch bei allen
kommunen an dieser stelle ganz herzlich
bedanken
der heutige gesetzentwurf zur änderung
des baugesetzbuches behandelt den
paragrafen 246 also sonder regelungen
für die genehmigung von
flüchtlingsunterkünften um mit hohem
tempo und genehmigungen für eine
begrenzte zeit zu erteilen das ist
fachlich eigentlich unumstritten es war
auch eine initiative des bundesrates mit
dem absatz 14 setzen wir eine regelung
wieder in kraft die eigentlich bis 2019
schon ausgelaufen war aber auch jetzt
wieder nur zeitlich befristet und im
kern geht es darum dass die höhere
verwaltungsbehörde in den meisten
ländern sind das die regierungspräsidien
in die lage versetzt werden
entsprechende voraussetzungen für den
schnellen bau von unterkünften zu
ermöglichen ich sage deutlich dazu
kommen publisher sprecher meiner
fraktion es geht nicht darum die
kommunale selbstverwaltung irgendwie
auszuhebeln sondern ganz im gegenteil
das wissen auch die kommunalen
spitzenverbände deswegen bedanken sie
sich auch dafür dass wir das machen
beziehungsweise tragen dass auch
uneingeschränkt mit aber um vielleicht
auch missverständnissen vorzubeugen es
geht nicht darum möglichst viele
unterkünfte in gewerbegebieten im
außenbereich oder sonstwo unterzubringen
sondern ganz im gegenteil am besten
erfolgt die aufnahme an integrierten
städten in den innenstädten und nicht am
rande oder gar in gewerbegebieten aber
es passt kann eine dauerhafte lösung
dann auch nur durch nachholende planung
im grunde genommen ergänzt werden ich
will das nicht im detail hier sozusagen
noch einmal darstellen ich will aber
noch einen punkt sagen zum thema unter
kunst der über die baurechtliche frage
hinaus geht es gibt schnelle hilfen zum
gegenwärtigen zeitpunkt auch seitens des
bundes beispielsweise hilft bei der
unterbringung die beamer die
bundesimmobilien anstalt die zum
gegenwärtigen zeitpunkt 60.000 plätze
vorgehalten hat von den 30.000 zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt noch frei sind das
ist glaube ich eine gute sache ich will
auch darauf hinweisen und erwähnen dass
die kfw ihr sofortprogramm mit einem
minus zinssatz von 250 millionen auf 500
millionen erweitert hat auch das ist
eine wichtige hilfe und ich habe den
dringenden appell auch dass wenn der
wenn die vereinbarung das nächste
treffen der ministerpräsidenten mit den
bundesräten bitte der bundesgasse
stattfindet ist zu konkreten auch
finanzielle zusagen kommt im april das
ist glaube ich auch wichtig und der
heute vorliegenden gesetzentwurf
ermöglicht dass auch hier mit
anzubringen was das baugesetzbuch an
bringt dafür herzlichen dank und ich
hoffe dass sie es ihre unterstützung
findet
ich schließe die aussprache wir kommen
zur abstimmung über den von den
fraktionen der spd bündnis 90/die grünen
und fdp eingebrachten gesetzentwurf zur
änderung des energiewirtschaftsgesetzes
zur einführung von füllstandes vorgaben
für gas speicher laden der ausschuss für
klimaschutz und energie empfiehlt in
seiner beschlussempfehlung auf
drucksache
1144 den gesetzentwurf der fraktionen
der spd bündnis 90/die grünen und fdp
auf drucksache
1024 in der ausschuss fassung anzunehmen
ich bitte diejenigen die dem
gesetzentwurf in der ausschuss fassung
zustimmen wollen um das handzeichen
danke bestimmt dagegen er enthält sich
danke der gesetzentwurf ist damit in
zweiter beratung mit den stimmen der
koalitionsfraktionen der
cdu/csu-fraktion der fraktion die linke
bei enthaltung der fdp fraktion
angenommen
dritte beratung und schlussabstimmung
ich bitte diejenigen die dem
gesetzentwurf zustimmen wollen sich zu
erheben
dann werden dagegen
er enthält sich
danke der gesetzentwurf ist mit den
stimmen der spd fraktion der fdp
fraktion der fraktion bündnis 90 die
grünen der cdu csu fraktion und der
fraktion die linke bei enthaltung der
fdp fraktion
das bedeutet also dass demnächst den
betreibern von gasspeichern
vorgaben gemacht werden wie sie ihre
speicher mindestens erfüllen müssen das
thema versorgungssicherheit
wird uns aber natürlich auch noch in
zukunft beschäftigen unter anderem haben
die usa und die eu ja zb einen
zusätzlichen kauf von flüssiggas
vereinbart